you've probably heard people make
comparisons between the United States in
the 1960s and the u.s. today there'd
been street protests a spotlight on
policing and a national discussion about
race equality and equity today more than
ever we see pundits and politicians
using the legacy of the civil rights
movement and its icons as spotter to
criticize social movements like black
lives matter that's the whole message I
think that dr. King tried to present and
I think you'd be appalled by the notion
that we're elevating some lives of
others think of President Trump as the
Martin Luther King of health care Oh
Geoffrey what happens when people neuter
the legacy of the civil rights movement
and then use that sanitized version to
critique today's activism hey fam I'm a
Mayan and this Sunday on aj+ were
exploring the true history of the civil
rights era and how people we lionize
like Martin Luther King jr. Rosa Parks
and Muhammad Ali were much bolder
riskier and more threatening to the
power dynamic than we've been taught
we've basically been getting a PG
version of the civil rights movement the
men who organized the rally work with
springing steps toward the speaker's -
they moved with good humor laughter and
saw so much of the civil rights movement
looked more like this
tense violent and life-threatening and
the doe toothpaste when we talk about
this time is Martin Luther King Junior's
the Reverend is arguably the movements
most well known leader but the truth is
that he was just one person in a
movement with differing ideologies for
achieving racial justice inequity goals
that relied heavily on the work and
sacrifices of black womens whose
contributions have been largely
overlooked we'll talk more about that a
little later
for now you should know that dr. Martin
Luther King jr. was much more than a
symbol for non-violence and his efforts
weren't warmly received or supported by
the nation's majority as Professor John
Powell explains dr. King when he was
alive was extremely unpopular people
were against most of his marches even
the church was against him so he was
going into very strong headwinds while
today the majority of Americans say they
believe the Civil Rights Act of 1964 was
a good thing at the time it didn't have
that much support from the masses a 1963
Gallup poll found 60% of Americans had
an unfavorable view of Martin Luther
King Jr's march on Washington that's
where he delivered his historic I have a
dream speech you know the one we so
often honor today and used to emphasize
the United States ideals King speeches
were way more radical than we choose to
remember in fact he was working on a
sermon called why America may go to hell
the day he died and things low approval
rating was not only because he was so
critical of the way society functions
but also that he was part of a larger
movement registering black voters and
organizing sit-ins at segregated
restaurants none of which were the right
sway to advocate for these causes
according to critics if that criticism
sounds familiar to you it's because the
pundits have used the same critiques
about the black lives matter movement
and sometimes they even invoke Kings
memory to do the work for example Alex
Jones's program posted a segment called
MLK supports Trump from the grave King's
legacy is so closely tied with politics
that an important point often gets
misplaced in our collective memory of
him
his critique of capitalism in a letter
to his wife Coretta he wrote today
capitalism has outlived its usefulness
it has brought about a system that takes
necessities from the masses to give
luxuries to the classes this was not
isolated to one letter either King often
spoke about how alleviating poverty was
important to the fight for justice in
1965 at Ebenezer Baptist Church in
Atlanta he said I've seen my dreams
shattered as I've been through
Appalachia and I've seen my white
brothers along with Negroes living in
poverty but when we put his I have a
dream speech on repeat it's easy to
forget all the ways he fought against
injustice 'as he also was against the
vietnam war and u.s. imperialism he once
said that the u.s. government was the
greatest purveyor of violence in the
world today and compared the war in
Vietnam to German concentration camps
the rebel Martin Luther King was a
social justice religious worker a
warrior or radical justice and inclusion
when people say this an extreme position
he would say oh it's okay to be extreme
if you're extreme in favor of love and
let's not forget the end to this story
because Martin Luther King did actually
die for what he believed in he
threatened the status quo to the extent
that he was assassinated another
important figure in the civil rights
movement and one of the few recognized
women is Rosa Park she's widely
described in the media like this
through her quiet eloquence this quiet
42 year old Rosa Parks and everyday
American that changed the course of
history the Rosa Parks story is often
told as if it were an accident that a
coincidental chain of events her being
tired after a long day of work her
fatigue leading unexpectedly to her
arrest led to the desegregation of the
bus system this was no accident she was
not just a woman who was simply weary
and on her way home from work she was
not just a seamstress this sort of this
false image of a woman she's quiet you
know she's a lot of a tenant that's not
who she was she was a fighter she was
fierce and guess what even though that
incident did happen that historic photo
of her on the bus is staged
rumors were being spread of Parks being
a communist and
Mexican depicting her as a fragile
everyday woman was a way for organizers
to get the public to sympathize with her
experience since an outspoken black
activist would have been a harder pill
to swallow that is allstar PR Parks was
an activist she worked for the
n-double-a-cp for years and investigated
sexual assaults of black people by white
men her bus protest was deliberate it
was part of an ongoing effort to
desegregate the bus system not only was
parks not the only person to refuse to
move from her seat it was also not the
first time she had done so the very same
driver that had her arrested had kicked
her off his bus before and after that
famous bus protest she continued her
political activism for decades we've
talked about faces synonymous with the
civil rights movement but there's one
man whose son don't recognize for his
dedication to equality and equity
Muhammad Ali literally gave up the best
boxing years of his career but what the
nation remembers is a whitewashed
version of the world's most influential
athlete Muhammad Ali is remembered today
I think with his political teeth largely
extracted people speak about him in
terms of being this figure of
reconciliation almost like a Buddha type
figure someone who's silent Ora made
people particularly white people feel
good about themselves
but the a lead that became revered in
the latter years of his life was a much
different ally than the one from his
height
the younger Ali spoke openly boldly
loudly about the experience of being a
black man in a racist society about
being Muslim and about his strong
beliefs on in justices throughout the
country since we helped build America to
be 50 the richest States on the planet
and Fault in all American wars to help
maintain an upholder government why not
should we have someone the land where we
can be able to construct quite simply he
made lots of people especially white
people really uncomfortable
he said he changed his name from Cassius
Clay to Muhammad Ali to denounce the
oppression white Christian culture have
had on black people like Martin Luther
King jr. he be madly opposed the Vietnam
War and was sentenced to five years in
prison for saying no to the draft a
sentence that was later overturned but
he lost his boxing license because of it
let me go shoot my brother are some
darker people some poor hungry people in
the mud a big powerful America and shoot
them for what they never call me
they never HP therefore no dogs will be
there Robbie Mouse nice dolly great I
killed my mother father ally retired in
1981 but he wasn't really embraced by
mainstream America until he lived the
torch at the 1996 Atlanta Summer Olympic
Games at that point he was an older man
with Parkinson's disease and showing
symptoms the mainstream media and
politicians like Bill Clinton and Orrin
Hatch only embraced Muhammad Ali when he
lost the power of speech and so once he
was unable to use that gift of gab to
decry US Empire to speak out for
Palestinian rights which is something he
believed in very strongly once he was
unable to do that then this incredibly
popular person was free for them to
embrace America found it so easy to love
Ali once he was silenced
which begs the question what does this
mean for the future of someone like
Colin Kaepernick now why is it important
to remember King was critical of
capitalism Rosa Parks was no ordinary
seamstress and Muhammad Ali wasn't
beloved by the majority in his prime
because by uplifting them as sanitized
icons were able to ignore the great
racial disparities that continued to
exist today
understanding what these icons stood for
helps contextualize the commitment many
of our generations leaders and movements
are making today I think what
politicians and the elites actually
figured out it toward the late 60s
beginning 70s was we can co-op the civil
rights movement we can embrace Cain but
still maintain segregated schools for
example segregated neighborhoods we
could still maintain segregated
boardrooms hey guys thanks for joining
us like share subscribe and join us next
week when we're gonna be doing a story
on punk music but what the twist I will
not be dancing or will I